how do you start living the life you
want when you don't have enough money um
there's this other guy on twitter liad
chabot he had a great tweet
where he said
not wanting something is as good as
having it
so
except for maybe one thing that you're
working on at a time i would suggest
that for everything else you should
cultivate not wanting it
indifference is actually
the ultimate superpower
if you want to win a negotiation you
just have to care less than the other
person if you want the upper-handed
relationship you just have to care less
than the other person
weirdly enough it even works in business
opportunities the less you kind of
genuinely want them
the more they're offered to you assuming
you have a certain level of skill set
i'm not saying be apathetic but i'm
saying that you kind of have to be
quantumous you have to be good with the
outcome either way you still do your
best job you still put in the effort
because that's who you are
um but you don't get attached to the
outcome and this is this is wisdom
that's as old as a hill this goes back
to the bhagavad-gita but yeah i think
detachment is good
because detachment is necessary for
peace and peace is necessary for
happiness so even though we're taught
and educated by society to be passionate
and not detached
i think it's okay to be passionate about
one thing at a time but you can't be
passionate about too many things
especially things you can't control if
you're passionate about things outside
of your control like politics
you're going to be miserable
rene gerard
gerardian's theory on mimesis is one
that peter thiel is famous for having
mentioned
um gerard was a polymath who basically
came up with this
uh theory that most of our desires it's
basically a three-part theory uh part
one
is that most of our desires are memetic
they're copied from other people so we
end up in competition with each other
fighting over a small set of things that
are just copied from each other and we
aren't following our true intrinsic
genuine desires
the second
part of this theory is that
people basically because they're
fighting over this stuff the society is
the way they settle these internal
conflicts is by creating a scapegoat and
by essentially killing the scapegoat
they um
basically achieve harmony within their
group again and then the third part of
his theory is that um
uh christianity this is where it gets
takes a little bit of a turn that
christianity is is a very rare
institution in that it defends against
scapegoating and says the person who
escaped in christianity's case jesus
is actually the one who's correct and
i'm way oversimplifying it
i think
i think it's worth reading gerard's
memetic theory and understanding it you
don't need to read all of his books some
of them are very long and can be painful
but you can find summary papers it's a
model that's worth knowing about i think
the
the most important part of the model um
that's worth tracking is just that the
part about mimesis that uh our desires
are copied from other people or socially
copied and i think that's an important
one and that feeds into
uh peter thiel's whole concept of don't
compete because when you're competing
with people a lot of times really you're
competing with them over things that you
copied from them and desires you copied
from them and this is very common in
business like you'll be running your
company and then a competitor shows up
and then you get obsessed with a
competitor
and then you start basically chasing
after the competitor and you lose track
of the fact that 99 of people out there
are not your customers and don't even
know what you're doing and you should be
going getting more customers not
focusing on your competitor and very
often you will end up basically just
both
doing following the same strategy
jumping back and forth in front of each
other when the correct answer was to
follow a completely different strategy
so i think that's the interesting
practical take away from from mimetic
theory
and i think another piece that's
important is don't scape
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you